welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode seven kotron
jairus's rigvangelion
from voltron to mafia films the power of
family has never been more potent than
in the hands of a giant incest baby
i'm gonna break down all the hidden
jokes and animation details that you
might have missed this episode we open
on the way to boob world
it's a word
yeah summer does that annoying thing of
holding out the last note thinking the
whole car
needs to hear her vocal solo yes i did
grow up with sisters
now the end credits actually score this
theme song
[Music]
rick spots a blue ferret gotron down on
the moon and suddenly swerves down to it
notice how morty's face gets smushed
against the glass hood when he does that
now they don't wear
spacesuits or helmets on this moon
surface but that blue-ish
atmosphere suggests there might be some
breathable air also this is a cartoon
magic xylophone i'm just gonna move on i
would draw my question
gotron is of course based on voltron
which was an adaptation of several
japanese anime series from toei the
basic premise of a team of five piloted
separate animalistic robots that come
together to form a super robot a premise
that you also saw in power rangers but
for rick this represents the perfect
outlet for his family of five to unite
without having to split up into a b plot
something he snapped at jerry about in
the decoys episode
i say we split up some of us take down
squids while the rest
agent b story is off the track
simultaneously no thank you
and he loves this simple idea of
assembly so much that he drunkenly
stacks it
exponentially 5 to 25 to 125 and so on
similar to how he used to get off on the
idea of unity's unimined
and using ferrets is fitting then
because ferrets are illegal in places
like california new zealand and
australia for fear that releasing them
in the wild will cause them to
overpopulate rapidly and damage
agriculture and native wildlife and
voice over narration begins
that's how it all began to my sister it
was just another game
but what she didn't know that was the
moment everything changed wait what
i had gotten my first taste of respect
and my first voiceover
and i knew then and there i wanted more
of both
hello using voiceover like this is of
course a nod to mafia films like
goodfellas which partly influenced this
episode similar to influencing the
episode of dan harmon's previous show
community
contemporary american poultry one of my
favorite episodes which had a similar
plot about the group getting too
greedy with a good thing and turning
against each other like mobsters
beth and jerry eat spaghetti a food that
they seem to eat a lot throughout this
episode just another nod to the italian
mafia film genre and rick says
let's just get gene from next door and a
homeless guy no hold on gene
the homeless yeah another mention of
next-door neighbor gene and rick using
the homeless like this is kind of a
go-to for him remember he used a
homeless guy to build his anatomy park
dream
by the way having a healthy diet and
getting all the nutrients i need are
both on my to-do list but
counting all the riboflavin or vitamin
whatever
i get every day is not always a priority
that's why i use
athletic greens to fill the nutritional
gaps in my diet whether i'm being good
and eating all my carrot sticks that day
or being a naughty pizza eating boy
more often the case if i have some
athletic greens in the morning
i know that my body is getting what i
need to be healthy athletic greens is
packed with 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food source ingredients it's great
for folks like myself looking to build
up and stick to a healthy habit
and who wants some nutritional insurance
to help with immune and gut health and
help me sustain energy throughout the
day athletic greens is available in the
u.s
canada uk and europe and it's super easy
to use no need for the 14 different
pills and capsules just one tasty powder
that mix is easy it's got all the
antioxidants probiotics and other words
i get pronounced that i know are
important for my health okay so this is
what i essentially do every morning
just opening up my packet here pouring
it in
give it a nice little mix up here
bottoms up actually tastes really good
so to get the athletic greens immunity
bundle that comes with a one-year supply
of vitamin d
plus five individual travel packs for
free with your first purchase just go to
athleticgreens.com new rockstars or
click that link in the description
summer defense or giant incest baby from
episode four
oh my god we made a giant incest baby oh
my god you might be a clone i exist
because you guys fail to abort me
we get the family we get not the one we
want yes makes reference again to beth
being a clone but also calling back her
own existential crisis from season one
when she found out she was an unplanned
pregnancy essentially summer's now kind
of doing her version of morty's pep talk
to her in that moment
nobody exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere
everybody's gonna die come watch tv now
the voiceovers return
something new was forming and i was at
the bottom of it i let morty have his
voice over
it's really all he had left okay can you
hear me or not do you mean can i summer
hear you no my voiceover can hear your
voice over what's the difference
one would be telepathy dumbass yeah
morty can consciously hear
both of their voice ovarians whereas
summer's host body and mind doesn't seem
to react at all to them i just think
it's an interesting reflection of how
morty is a bit more in tune with any
foreign influences in his mind remember
back in the total rickall episode it was
morty who figured out the gimmick of
those mined parasites just a way of
showing how morty has been around the
block a few more times when it comes to
crazy crap that rick has inflicted upon
them the assembly split screen montage
is
pretty much shot for shot recreations of
the voltron forum sequence
and then with the settings of a volcano
a waterfall a jungle etc they pretty
much parallel the zords of the power
rangers
coming from different geographical
locations now the giant insect monster
looms over a version of golden gate
bridge on this other planet though
notice
it doesn't actually attack the bridge it
just screams at the drivers
because as we find out in the
post-credits scene these beings are
really just trying to communicate the
cure for aids in fact the bridge is only
damaged when gotron knocks the monster
into it now rick knows this first attack
wave was pointless
it really is to just tee up their
assembly activating link doc
inner morphs ratified post atrinos
maximize
yeah just like the random activation
phrase of voltron
activate interlock dinotherms connected
intracells up as well as the animation
of their assembly their sword formation
those all match up and he says go go
team it's gotron time just like go go
power rangers
and it's kill pose with its back to the
monster it's just like how the megazord
would always turn to camera and let the
monster explode
now right after the kill notice rick is
drinking from his flask again
showing how living out this fantasy is
causing him to revert back to his old
habits and toxic tendencies
rick invites the five families of course
like the five families in the godfather
big fat rick and the tux is based on don
vito corleone
marlon brando ricardo montoya of course
based on tony montana from starface al
pacino hot head rick is based on sonny
from the godfather veto's son
played by james khan who like that
character always flies off the handle
this is the family that made a giant
incest baby
had the government launching into space
it's still floating around out there
somewhere are we ever gonna live that
down
yeah clearly the writers anticipated
that introducing giant incest baby in
episode 4 would lead to some backlash
now sure it is possible that a lot of
these lines could have been added right
in the last few days via adr but
remember episode 7 leaked shortly after
the sperm monster episode came out so
they wouldn't have had a lot of time to
do it and in retrospect one might argue
they
intentionally released it early after
that backlash came out and the fact that
they ended this episode with the fully
animated sequence of naruto coming back
means that they knew what they were
doing when they introduced an incest
baby they had a plan going into this and
they know where the line is with their
audience but little detail here i like
how summer's eyes
dart over to rick when the baby comes up
because she secretly spent more time
with that incest baby on mars than the
rest of the family knew about hot head
rick's ferret explodes
kind of like the death trap that was set
for sunny and the godfather and then
when that happens summer coldly closes
the garage door
leaving out morty and jerry kind of like
how michael corleone has the door closed
on kaye at the end of the godfather it's
also kind of like when hank schrader
closes the garage door to trap and walt
with him on breaking bad
then we get this montage showing the
five heads murdering their enemies all
at once much like the baptism massacre
sequence on the godfather
and they form the go-go tron 25 family
members in one
actually in the grade you can see how
little ricky wrap it up is shorter in
his frame and if you listen closely to
the lyrics of the song it amazingly
fuses the mafia in
anime genres
[Music]
the go-go-tron curb stomps a monster on
a dam he shoots one in an already dug
grave
fills cement and buckets around each of
the feet of a centipede meanwhile
summer holy crap appears in yo-yo rick's
hotel room where he's apparently
yo-yoed his male lover to death maybe
like in that godfather part 2 scene when
senator geary wakes up with a dead sex
worker in his bed
this is really messed up morty narrates
i ended up the left foot of the left
foot
i guess because our robot didn't have an
remember in the first go-tron
jerry was
its left foot suggesting that this
position is the bottom of rick's totem
pole over by rick's blueprint wall there
is a
pile of finished flasks one blueprint is
pinned with a
trench knife yikes and rick has insanely
written buy more parts more more more
and then pi to the square root of 8098z
which is kind of one digit off from
z boobs and go parentheses tron
plus xxx he's just used the word gotron
to make a math formula now the nightclub
is decorated with g
lights and an ice sculpture of a ferret
gotron and rick introduces summer
this is our queef
our queen yeah summer is unfazed by this
gaffe
she waves anyway just happy to have
rick's approval and little ricky wrap it
up has a martini in his coat pocket
ready to toast at a moment's notice now
morty ends up in the
car with other gotron pilots whose eyes
and teeth plus signs and mannerisms all
follow the anime tropes and stereotypes
what your grandpa did is called
appropriation
not cool yeah also their movement is
more stilted you can really see it on
the opening of the briefcase of boob
bucks
animated to match the lower frame rate
of old school anime but morty snaps when
the guy threatens to kill him which is
such a funny reaction that's
increasingly becoming the case with
morty anytime his life is threatened by
he doesn't respect it's just
like how he responded the teen of tear
by
biting off the guy's finger he even
pulls the trigger right at this dude's
face but at the last second the gun gets
diverted and takes out the driver back
outside the nightclub there's some
graffiti on the wall reading get caponed
for the chicago gangster but with owned
in it you get it and then on the
dumpster gun
dumb that's also the name of the
magazine kendra reads later both for
gundam wing
little ricky wrapping up dies
lil ricky i'm all wrapped up summer guys
i know you don't trust me
but what have we become yeah morty talks
through his death
easy bath jerry and summer all weep
tears leading to beth payne off her son
this is sixteen thousand dollars we got
from the deep state for stepping on that
trailer park that should be enough for
school lunch and home repairs
now i gotta turn my back on you good
lord just like that scene in goodfellas
when paulie pays henry off and then
turns his back on him making henry cry
so the warehouse of the go-go-go-tron
okay the g3 is
massive you can actually see the
original tier one ferrettron
now appearing really small compared to
the full assembled form it's actually
similar to the sense of scale
used with the jaeger factory in pacific
rim and then drunk rick says
and then the gotrons make the gotrons
make the gotrons make the gotrons
telling us that his ultimate dream is
probably five to the power of
five just a bit of obsessive numeric
harmony that's actually reflected in its
g3 drawing which is based on leonardo da
vinci's vitruvian man sketch which he
drew to show the humanistic ratio and
godly design of the human body with its
five points
also notice on the paper underneath that
the letters b-l-m
how very rick of him to keep his
activism buried like that also on his
shelf are some gotron's arranged like
gundam figures and when kendra does her
little salute there is an anime sound
effect she's got an entire workforce
back home morty sips the hi-c
ecto cooler it looks like just like we
saw kid loki drinking on loki and if you
remember one of the treasures that rick
found among the sex dragons vault last
season
and summer returns with a confession i
appreciate it but there's something else
too
i've been really sensitive about family
lately because of something i've been
keeping secret
okay who's on the supreme court in what
state do we live in it's been years
since i've thought about this yeah jerry
just
jumps right to abortion recognizing how
now with the 6-3 conservative majority
on the u.s supreme court
abortion rights are now increasingly
dependent on whatever state you live in
summer reveals that her giant incest
baby is still
alive and that she's been training them
on a secret base on mars because she
feels like a fifth wheel in the family
no other family member to pair off with
really that five pilot gotron was the
first setup that gave her an equal role
in function in the family that didn't
force her to
pick sides with a two or three person
grouping in the family rick's g3 cockpit
is a freaking mansion it's got a statue
of gotron holding a planet and a pool
painting spirits statues holding
candelabras and pale through their own
heads
which you could see as a metaphor for
how these ferret go trons are really the
instruments of their own destruction
really this gilded setup is obviously an
homage to tony's home in scarface and
when the anime pilots betray rick it
sets up this direct scarface homage
hello to my little me big
but the incest baby arrives to save the
day
my god it's beautiful
again the music from stanley kubrick's
2001 to space odyssey the star child
scene and notice how its wristband shows
the government called it
weapon one meta 80085 again
boobs and made in las vegas and summer
named him naruto after the manga series
the anime pilots get sucked out the
airlock with their helmets lowered you
can actually see their faces turning
purple and their eyes popping out and
naruto crushes the g3 head and they save
rick with one last zipline jerry gets
trapped outside the home shield as the
monster attacks just like morty actually
worried he would back in the decoys
episode
oh sh decoy family i think dad was still
outside really if you think about it
this monster probably wouldn't have
attacked jerry just screamed at him in
an unintelligible alien language the
cure for aids
meanwhile their voiceovers are revealed
to be from voice ovarians
nested in their ear canals the way they
look when they're pulled out all gooey
is much like the gross insect-like
tracker bot from neo's belly button in
the matrix and in the post-credits scene
yes the monsters are revealed to be
compassionate beings from another
dimension just trying to share the cure
for aids their classroom walls read to
serve and protect and on the whiteboard
protect at all costs warn them teach
them very similar brains but also loud
noises because they stupidly believe
that just screaming louder will make
them clearer the poor creature tries to
communicate the aids cure
one part lemon juice four bay leaves a
pinch of sea salt but is then killed
we'll never know even though all these
things are in most of our kitchens you
can support new rockstars by checking
out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars we'll see
you next week thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you